- [Interviewer] Okay,
Ryley, Ryley, welcome back.
- Hello.
- [Interviewer] How you been?
It's been six, seven months
since we talked to you.
- [Ryley] I think it's been nine.
No.
- [Interviewer] It was last summer.
- [Ryley] It's been eight.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
probably around that.
- [Ryley] April. March, April.
- [Interviewer] I really
enjoyed your last talk.
'Cause you're so
well-spoken, so intelligent.
You speak so beautifully
about what you've been through
and what you're going through.
Well, tell me what's going on, now.
Where you at?
- I suppose, since last time we spoke,
I've been struggling with
the want or need to get
into treatment or let alone
even get out of Los Angeles.
- [Interviewer] You were leaving for rehab
the day we did the last interview.
- I thought I was
(Interviewer laughs)
But, it turned out the guy I was with,
they pretty much just all lied to me
so that they could get her into treatment.
And, I wasn't along for
the ride on that one.
So it is what it is.
But recently, actually
what's funny is I'm planning
on going to Orange County to
go through a treatment center
down there, as soon as possible really.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
You spoke a lot last time
about what your childhood was like
and the abuse you got from your dad.
And the more I've learned since that talk,
that that's everything.
That's the core where it all stems from.
All this abuse, all the drug addiction,
all the self destruction,
self destruction you see
on my channel kind of stems from that.
I would call it rewiring of your brain
when you get that kind of abuse.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] And then it's almost like
your efforts to do the right thing,
just get turned upside down by
your self destructive nature
and there you are, back
in on the street again.
- Yeah, that's basically
what's been going on lately.
I moved to North Hollywood for a while
and then recently month and a
half ago, I moved back here,
because I ruined the housing
situation I was in over there.
Like, I had one opportunity to take
from somebody that I shouldn't have
and I fucking did it.
Like, I took the chance,
you know what I mean?
I weighed my options and I took the chance
and they knew immediately it was me
because I'm not gonna lie
about it when I'm confronted.
And like I was like, yeah, I did that.
And that's how it's been for me.
I'll go like two months, three months,
everything good make the right choices
and then I'll make one wrong decision.
And my consequences are
bad, usually very bad.
- [Interviewer] Is stealing in your nature
or is it just the drugs that
make you do this kind of stuff?
- It's the lack of finances
lately in the last eight weeks,
I haven't been had any access
to my money through unemployment.
Because they canceled my card
and I've been having troubles
getting it back in the
mail for some reason.
So that lack of any money
to survive at all has,
which I've been at in the past.
It's just been like
crucial, like fucked up.
Like I can't, it's, I've
almost died because of this,
'cause I have no money.
You know what I mean?
And I don't like to steal
but when I see an
opportunity to do something
where I can make money for survival,
for the drugs that I need,
for the food I need,
for the housing I need.
Sometimes I take that chance.
- [Interviewer] And last
time you were using heroin?
- Right.
- [Interviewer] Is that continued?
- I still sometimes do.
Within the last month I've
started using fentanyl.
I started smoking it.
I don't know how much
better or worse that is.
'Cause I smoked that and
I don't shoot it but,
it's much more strong and it
when I don't have it, I feel even worse
and it's scaring me.
The progression of it,
is really scaring me.
And I just, that's what's
pushing me to quit right now,
to go to rehab again.
Because, I know if I
continue with the fentanyl,
it's gonna get really bad, really quick.
And pretty soon when I don't have it,
I'm not gonna be able to move,
which is a scary place to be in.
I don't want nothing
controlling me like that.
- [Interviewer] And you're
intelligent enough to know better
but it's not about intelligence here is?
- It never was.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about drug addiction from-
- From my standpoint?
- [Interviewer] It's such a-
- It's a conniving thing.
It doesn't matter if you're the smartest
or dumbest person on earth,
you can be the smartest person on earth
and have no addiction in your family
and have a good upbringing
and do heroin 10 times
and not be addicted.
Or you could have the same situations
and do it once and become addicted.
So it's really fucking confusing.
It doesn't make any sense.
I think everyone's just different
and our brains are wired differently.
And sometimes we use
is, we'll use something
and we'll discover it to
be a crutch very quickly.
And, I think that's that
determining factor of
whether or not we become addicts or not.
It's, I think the environment
has a lot more to do
with it now than I ever thought before.
- [Interviewer] Environment being like,
your current environment or-
- Surroundings. Yeah.
Like this city, for instance,
even famous people do
like methamphetamine.
It's like normal, people are used to it.
It's okay.
You know, I thought that
was really funny and weird.
But I found that out one night
because it's a very
popular drug in the city.
- [Interviewer] Crystal meth?
- Right.
- Yeah.
- It's not so much cocaine
anymore, like it was.
It's more crystal meth and I've realized
that I'm not so much, I'm not
doing that as much anymore
because, I feel weird on it.
There's gotta be something else in it that
just doesn't make me feel right.
- [Interviewer] What did the
crystal meth do it for you?
- Well, I've been tested
on a, like a 16 panel test
after I know that I've just
been using heroin and meth
and I've popped for five
different drugs, like MDMA.
I don't even remember.
I don't even remember, but
there was two hallucinogenics
and then PCP, methamphetamine
and amphetamine
and that's just from the meth.
And so if that's what's in there
like why would I wanna introduce
that to my body anymore?
- [Interviewer] I'm not
sure you know exactly
what you're buying on the street anyway?
- No.
No, and I'm not sure I
should be doing that anyways.
- [Interviewer] That's right.
- It's just it's, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you think if you went
to this Orange County rehab
and somehow got clean or
gotten a much better place
where you using a lot less perhaps
with Suboxone or whatever,
that that in combination with some therapy
to work out what you
went through as a child,
might get you to a point
where you're not so prone to a reuse?
- Well, I'll be honest here,
I think it all came down to
my relationship with my ex
and my son and that whole catastrophe
is what kept me sick for so long.
I think now that she made
it so we're separated,
I finally had the chance
to think about myself
and actually, if I'm going to go to rehab
and have the ability to think
about myself and only that,
because I'm not gonna be worried
about a relationship I no longer have,
if that makes sense?
At this point, I'm just worried about
being a part of my son's life,
you know, because she's
gotten custody back
within the last month
'cause she's been clean
for a month or a year and two months.
And so now I have this opportunity
where I can selfishly do it
and it might actually work.
And that's a scary thing for me.
So at the same time, I don't wanna do it.
Which doesn't make any sense either, but.
- [Interviewer] The
life you're living now,
you're living on the street?
- [Ryley] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] In a tent?
- [Ryley] Recently, no.
- [Interviewer] You're just-
- [Ryley] I've been here and there
at people's places, in
apartments or on the street.
Rarely in apartments, maybe twice a week.
Mainly on the streets, at buddies' places
because it's just been
real dangerous lately.
(Ryley laughs)
- [Interviewer] At night down
here is a very different scene
than during the day.
- [Ryley] Yeah.
Yeah. It's scary, man.
And you better make sure that
you don't fuck anyone over
because people have ability
to make things happen,
that would be out of anyone's imagination.
And it's really scary.
- [Interviewer] Addiction
is such a, perplexing thing
for an outsider to watch
'cause it's like,
I see very clearly how you
could be living a great life
with your kid, with your, you know,
repair the relationship with your ex,
get everything together.
Do whatever it takes to
get your life together
and you have the blocks that you have,
that you're experiencing
right now are so strong
that you just can't.
You're smart enough to figure that out,
but you just can't, it seems.
- Yeah.
I even have somebody that's
willing to come pick me up
at any time within a day's notice
to take me to Orange County.
And I can't seem to find
the right day, the
courage to do it really.
- [Interviewer] Is it courage?
- Yeah. I think I'm just afraid.
- [Interviewer] But what
I'm learning with every,
all of these issues that you see,
all these problems people are
experiencing on my channel,
that courage is very close
to the core of all of it.
You know, lack of courage stops you,
the fear of what might happen,
the fear of getting clean.
The fear of living,
being successful in life
and being fulfilled.
- It's uncomfortable.
- [Interviewer] Is it
because you don't deserve it,
you feel like you don't deserve it?
- Honestly, I felt like
I deserved everything.
I used to feel like I deserved
a lot more than I got.
And, at this point where I'm at now,
I do think I deserve a little
bit more than I have but-
(Interviewer laughs)
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(Ryley laughs)
- But I also put myself
in these situations.
I could be gone, I mean, fuck,
I walk like nine miles a day.
I could be out of LA in a day, you know,
it's not that hard.
But the lifestyle is just it
becomes such a routinely thing
and you start making friends with people.
And when I came back
here I was very welcomed
by much of the community
which was shocking to me.
- [Interviewer] You came back downtown?
- Yeah.
Which was pretty shocking.
Everyone was really happy to see me,
but I think it was for the wrong reasons.
But you know, we're in
it together, out there,
you know what I mean?
And the people who live out here
that have it better than us.
They really have a hard time understanding
or even wanting to connect thoughts like,
they don't wanna connect with me.
They don't want to understand
what it's like for me
who was much recently in
their shoes, now homeless
which a lot of people are
becoming because of Coronavirus.
But people are starting
to figure out that,
soon I mean, if shit gets
worse with Coronavirus
and all that stuff, a
lot more people are going
to become homeless and be
in the same situation I'm in
and it's just gets bad
because then you're introduced
to drugs and alcohol
and fucking prostitution
and whatever, illegal everything.
- [Interviewer] The drugs numb the pain
of whatever you're going through.
- Yeah. It's the thing to do.
It makes the time go by.
And I don't have to think about
what a piece of shit I am, if I'm high.
That's really what it comes down to
because I can't even
run out of dope without,
I start freaking out if
I'm gonna run out of dope
because I know I'll start
thinking and I'll start feeling
and that's just where I'm at now.
- [Interviewer] Well, Ryley,
I wish you the best of luck.
Hope you make it to Orange County.
Hope you find the courage to do it
and stick with it and complete it.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And get back to Seattle.
Is that where your son is?
- I think I'm gonna stay out here
because my ex has a place
in San Clemente, you know.
- [Interviewer] With your son?
- I would.
I would like to probably
move out to Orange County.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
That's a beautiful place.
- [Ryley] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Wish you the best of luck.
- [Ryley] Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.